So we all know what being in an unhealthy relationship looks like, right?
Like, what are some traits that instantly come to mind?
Being overly critical of each other,
You used to be funny. Now all your videos are like this advice and motivational bullshit.
Being jealous,
Where are you and your grandma going?
Trying to control your partner's actions,
You're a Catholic now!
The longest time, I've wondered, like,
What actually defines a healthy relationship?
How do you quantify that?
Well, my therapist said that every relationship can be categorized into three different kinds.
There's living together but separate,
codependency,
and then the sweet spot where you have your own identity
but you share certain aspects of your life with your partner.
In a healthy relationship,
you spend time away from each other.
I miss you.
-I miss you too.
No, I miss you more!
-No, I do!
Send me a dick pic.
You continue living your life independently
and grow as a person.
I'm gonna eat this entire fucking pizza.
And your partner supports that.
-I'm so proud of you, baby.
I just wish you would've saved a piece for me.
You're also insanely happy for each other's success.
That dick pic is phenomenal!
The lighting, the filter...
Your camera skills have gotten so good.
So, if you're in an unhappy or codependent relationship,
I encourage you
to go to couple's therapy
or... try to seek out someone who will give you that healthy relationship that you deserve.
Anyway, as you may have noticed
there have been extravagant landmarks in the background of this video
and that's because Contiki was so kind to send me to Italy
I've been to Rome, Florence, and Venice and it has been such an amazing experience.
So, thank you so much for sending me.
You can go ahead! Thank you.
-Thank you
I've had so much food,
I've made so many friends
and it's been a while since I've traveled the world
so it's great to see this kind of amazing, beautiful shit!
Anyway, I'm Anna Akana
You, stay awesome.